>> Sean: THE MEDIA IS FILMING
AT THE MOUTH AWAITING DETAILS OF
A LEAK OF JAMES COMEY'S UPCOMING
TELL-ALL BOOK.
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW CNN COVERED
THE "BOMBSHELLS" EARLIER TODAY.
YOU CANNOT MAKE THIS STUFF UP.
>> SOME EXPLOSIVE NEW EXCERPTS
FROM THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY'S NEW BOOK.
IF YOU READ THE STORY IN
"THE NEW YORK POST."
IT'S GOT SOME TRULY SALACIOUS
DETAILS OF CONVERSATION THAT THE
PRESIDENT SUPPOSEDLY HAD WITH
COMEY.
>> RIGHT, SO WE KNEW THERE WAS
GOING TO BE SOME BOMBSHELLS IN
HERE.
THIS CERTAINLY IS A BIG ONE.
I WANT TO READ JUST A FEW OF THE
QUOTES FROM "THE NEW YORK POST"
AS OBTAINED, THE COMEY MEMOIR AS
OBTAINED BY "THE NEW YORK POST"
OBTAINED BY "THE NEW YORK POST""
REGARDING COMEY AND TRUMP.
HE BROUGHT UP WHAT HE CALLED THE
GOLDEN SHOWER THING, ADDING THAT
IT BOTHERED HIM IF THERE WAS
"EVEN A 1% CHANCE" MELANIA
THOUGHT IT WAS TRUE.
IT GOES ON.
HE JUST RULED ON UNPROMPTED,
EXPLAINING WHY IT COULDN'T
POSSIBLY BE TRUE, ENDING BY
SAYING HE WAS THINKING OF
ASKING ME TO INVESTIGATE THE
ALLEGATIONS TO PROVE IT WAS A
LIE.
I SAID IT WAS UP TO HIM.
>> Sean: THAT IS CNN'S
BOMBSHELL?
THAT IS COMEY'S BOMBSHELL?
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA.
JASON CHAFFETZ.
IF LIES WERE PAID FOR, WE DIDN'T
KNOW PROBABLY AT THE TIME, IF
LIES WERE TOLD ABOUT YOU,
WOULDN'T YOU, YOU ARE TALKING TO
THE FBI DIRECTOR AND IT'S A
FAKE, PHONY DOSSIER TO
MANIPULATE THE MINDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND IT'S FULL
OF LIES YOU KNOW AREN'T TRUE.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SAY?
CAN YOU FIND OUT THAT'S NOT
TRUE?
ISN'T THAT THE NATURAL REACTION?
>> ALTHOUGH WE KNOW KNOW FOR
SURE IS THAT JAMES COMEY IS A
LIAR, AND CNN ARE A BUNCH OF
PERVERTS.
THAT'S ALL YOU NEED, THAT'S THE
BOMBSHELL.
THE PRESIDENT KNEW IT WASN'T
TRUE BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S TRUE
BECAUSE IT WAS A RUSSIAN
INFORMATION OPERATION PAID FOR
BY HILLARY, AND HE WANTS TO HAVE
HIS DIRECTOR OF THE FBI PROVED
TO THE WORLD, NOT JUST HIS WIFE,
AS YOU WOULD WANT, THAT IT ISN'T
TRUE.
THESE GUYS ARE SO DISCONNECTED
FROM REALITY AND SO DISCONNECTED
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT NOBODY
WATCHES THEM AND THEY HAVE TO
PAY FOR AIRPORTS TO PUT THEIR
SHOWS ON.
>> Sean: GOOD POINT.
TOUCHE.
THERE IS A BIGGER ISSUE
CONGRESSMAN, AND IT IS THAT
LIBERALS HATED JAMES COMEY.
HARRY REID WANTED HIM OUT.
THAT HE SHOULDN'T BE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
NOW YOU SEE THIS GUY.
I THINK HE HAS LEGAL ISSUES.
TELL ME IF I'M WRONG.
LICKING PRIVILEGED INFORMATION.
LEAKING IT TO SOMEBODY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF GETTING A SPECIAL
COUNSEL APPOINTED.
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUARY
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUAR2
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUAR1
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUAR7
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUARW
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUARE
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUARN
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUARH
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUARE
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUARS
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUARI
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUARD
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUART
DID HE LIE TOOK TRUMP IN JANUARA
THE DOSSIER WAS ON VERIFIED AND
SALACIOUS OR WHEN THEY WERE
PRESENTING INTO A FISA COURT
JUDGE IN A FISA APPLICATION TO
SPY ON AN AMERICAN AS THE
GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO SAYS, THE
BULK OF INFORMATION AS ANDREW
WEISSMANN SAID, NO DOSSIER, NO
FISA WARRANT REQUEST OR